so the agenda for today would be to I
will do a small introduction to Bloss
two then how to extend Bloss two via
plugins um I will discuss also how to do
automatic compression tuning with with B
tune and I will finish with uh with some
conclussions so let's start with a with
a gentle introduction to to blos to blos
to so blos to it's it's both a c and
python Library it's also a simple format
so the the complete specification is
less than three
300 lines of text so this is is very
simple um also it supports full 63 bit
containers so that means that you can
store essentially
any any data for any practical uh
capacity to nowadays uh it is also a
fully dimensional uh support fully
dimensional double partitioning I am
going to to explain this with a little
more of more of detail uh it also
supports different codex and filters and
um and it's also it supports metallers
for adding info for applications and
users so here you you see the typical
block to
container um in the top we see the
header where different applications can
can
write their own header there and then
the data section is um is composed by
different CHS okay and the chunks are
splited again in what we call internally
blocks and these two components are what
we call the double partitioning right
because it's not all the single
partitioning by chance but also a double
one with blocks
as so why double partitioning or second
partition it's it's interesting for a
dimensional data so if you see on the
left it is how hdf5 or Zar or others
containers Works uh they they only have
one level of of partitioning so that
means that if you are interested just in
a small part of this Cube for example
this chunk that means that you need to
decompress the whole Chun in order to
get to get access to to that data on his
hand um blast to uh introduces a second
level of partitioning and that means
that every every Cube here is subdivided
again in in in in a second partition
with a small with a smaller cubes and
that means that if you're interested in
just a part small part of of this Cube
you will only need to to De compress the
the affected blocks or the affected
blocks in in that partition and that
LEDs to much more selective and and
faster queries in general
so here it's a a glimpse on the API for
for blos so here for example we are
creating um uh an end dimensional array
which is 4 by4 here and um with the
field value nine here and then we see
that we can resize
um we can resize the the array as well
uh to to make it larger and then it
supports also setting operations here we
have uh an example of the output here is
are the N that the of the initial of the
initial array then the Reise operations
filled everything with
zeros the expansion of the Ray and then
this a this this rectangle of eight is
is the the the result of this uh
assignation uh statement here right so
it's uh it's it's very it's very easy to
use and it tries to mimic npy API as
much as possible you can have a look at
the at the reference
here okay
okay so BL to is not only meant for for
be used in a standalone mode uh it is
also uh meant to make other formats more
efficient so here I am going to discuss
the hdf5 case hdf5 is is a very well
spread format especially on scientific
but also in in business application
ations and Pi tables and ice5 Pi are two
of the
most spread wrappers for 2
hdf5 so here we can see that
um um for starting like a here we are
storing a four dimensional array and
here we are doing different slies uh for
example in dimension zero Dimension one
dimension two and dimension three for
for the four dimensional array right
here in in the in the y axis we have a
throw put in megabytes per
second we can see how uh if we use the
regular uh filter approach with hdf5 in
BL two we can get uh this performance in
blue for for pi tables and in green for
H5 Pi however if we uh tickle uh tickle
things and we we do a more optimized um
use of Bloss to layer in both P tables
and H5 Pi we can see that we can get
Much More Much More performance when we
are getting for example this these
slices and this is because we are we are
leverage in the second partition right
um in this case P tables in red it's
it's a bit more performance than H5 P
because um the optimization in h55
happen and at the PIP level whereas for
p tabl integration has been done much
more low level in at at the SE level and
this is the reason but typically you can
expect um as you can see between five or
and eight times better speed by using BL
Tool uh with the second partition
and optimizing for for the comp
partition okay
now regarding file sizes uh BL 2 also
comes with a special Machinery that uh
can optimized for for sparse arrays so
essentially what what's going on is that
blos implements a a very fast and very
easy to uh to run uh um run length
compression um code um codc and that
means that for example when we are
compressing like a big uh 3D cube from
from the Gia Mission I I did um you can
you can
find uh this uh these details on the Gia
mission on a recent talk that I did on
on
CPI
2023 and but the idea is that um when
you are compressing that um with Bloss
two you get uh for example here we are
using uh blos SC Z codc and um I mean BL
2 can use more than half or less than
half of the space that it takes BL one
for example so for example here is uh BL
two and bl two with h5i and red as well
and here it's in red and in Violet it's
Zar and h5i with plus one and here is
the difference between BL two and plus
one when we're using Z standard the
differences are still uh larger and we
can see that BL two in combination with
with Z standard provides the best um the
best compression ratio for for this SPS
data set that is holding
8 trillion 8 trillion cells that it's
almost eight
terabytes so BL Tu pleta standard can
pack this entire uh gu array uh in less
than 2 gabes so that means a compression
ratio of more than 4,000 which is which
is pretty
good so let me finish this gentle
introduction to to Bloss to to by saying
that we have a python BL 2 has a
counterpart which is called C BL 2 and
it which is a C library for uh with a
lowlevel API for for other languages to
use and it leverages BL to
multi-dimensional capabilities uh from
other language like languages like rust
Julia r or whatever actually the the ND
array python class that I've sh I have
shown some some slides ago uh it's it's
a very shallow wrapper on top of of the
CBL to rivalry so that's interesting in
order to to make other uh languages to
leverage uh BL to it's not only for for
for
python okay so this is the introduction
to to BL two now the dynamic plugins
um so you can extend BL to also via
Dynamic plugins uh although BL to
supports a wide range of codex and
filters right off the Box uh there is
always a knit that is not well covered
by the standard s and this is why BL two
allow users to implement their own their
own ones and register them for being
used automatically here it's um there is
a there is a Blog where it is explained
how you can register your own plugins
okay so how does it work so whenever CBL
receives a request for using a dynamic
Cod codec ID that is not registered it
uh well it's it's locally registered
only it will dynamically load the D the
dll library so here is the CBL to
library and then whenever
uh the user requires um a codec or
filter which has a different ID that is
in inside of the C blos it tries to use
the open and loot library in order to
load the the codc uh dynamically the the
dynamic library from the operating
system and then it uses the compress and
the and decompress in order to to do the
all the job okay let's uh let's retake
so I think I started with the dynamic
plugins like 3 minutes ago Let's uh
quickly recap what
um from the pros ah pros and cons oh
okay not not that bad okay
good so pros and cons and yeah so the pr
is that is very easy to install because
uh you can provide
um
um wheels for for the plugins and there
is support for C C++ and and R as well
the cons is that um I mean creating a
plugin for BL two it's a little bit more
work to to create but we are providing
an example with detailed instructions
here okay so you can you can follow it's
it's a full full example where you can
you can follow all the steps for doing
that and also for creating wheels for
for as a practical example let
me let me
um introduce BL 2 Gro which is a plugin
for JP 2000 so it's a ly compressor so
typically BL2 normally only includes
lossless compressors so this is a good
contribution for for for for BL
two um as you know jpeg 2000 is a high
high quality lossy compression for
images um for doing this plugin we we CH
we have chosen with gr which is an open
source JP 2000
implementation by unboxer and you can
you can uh install it very easily with
with the with the binary
will uh here is an example of use from
python uh let me show you how how it
works so here on the left we have the
the original the original image without
uh uh with with lossless compression and
then here it's uh um it's jpeg 2000 via
Gro and and you can see that even if the
size is three times less I mean
the we are losing very very little
details so this uh I mean this codec is
really nice for for compressing for
compressing images in in BL too even if
we choose more extreme lossy compression
parameters uh we can see that uh for
example uh in this case we are reducing
a factor of 10 with on on the right side
uh with um um with in respect to the to
the lossless image we can see that we
see appar very apparent artifacts but
the image is still oish right so yeah
that's a that's a pretty good
implementation and it's a it's a very
nice example of how you can extend Bloss
to with your own
CeX okay so this is um uh for U for
codex now for uh let's um explain a
little bit about B tune so B tune it's
uh it's about making making compression
Better B tune is exactly it's it's a
state um machine uh
where the package has different states
and in every state um it is valuated the
different uh different comparation
parameters like codec filter and Shuffle
and size number of threads different
different
parameters so for example here you can
see an example of that how it's how that
works so at the beginning in the initial
State uh different codc are are tested
with in combination with different
filters okay and then uh um some scores
are evaluated and vune keeps track of
the best results so far right and it it
is uh the best results are marked and uh
they are suggested to to be used in the
end okay so this is how it works and you
can see the flow with the different
states in the the ma
state so this is how it
works but also it can also be trained to
find the best codec and filter with
using deep
learning um actually there are three
operation mainly operation modes for
bitun the first that I have shown is the
bitun genetic because it's essentially a
genetic algorithm that test different
combinations of parameters to select the
best
combinations then there is B models uses
um deep learning uh in this mode you
send uh or theel the development team
helps you finding a n network model
adapted to your data sets for for past
overation and then there is B Studio
where you can use the training package
uh locally to generate your own models
for your for your data sets by
yourself installing installing bitun is
very easy it's it it works like a like a
plugin so you can install typically with
with Pip and using it is is easy you
typically provide a a hint to to B tune
where you specify the tradeoff that you
want for for your compression so for
example if this tradeoff value is near
zero that means that you prefer more
speed than compression ratio whereas if
the tradeoff is is towards one that
means
that compression ratio is more important
than the speed right and then you
activate also the tracing so you can see
how the how the machine state is is
evolving towards
time um there are several tutorials that
I already done um the first one is the I
did that uh uh a couple of hours ago in
this in this conference and you can you
can have a look at the at the tutorial
also online if you are interested in in
trying
that
okay uh B models as I said uh um
typically bitun uh can be trained also
for for data sets uh so that means that
bitun can infer in real time the right
combination of cod on filter that s the
requirements for for different CHS okay
that you are that you are compressing so
you can favor speed favor compression
ratio or tradeoff everything
automatically after the training has
been done so essentially what is done
it's uh the training process generates a
Model A NE Network model and here we
have an example of the prediction for
the for the Gaia data
set where we see that depending on the
tradeoff different combinations are are
chosen here are estimations of the
compression ratio compression speed and
compression decompression speed in
gigabytes per
second and here we see an example of the
speed of course when you when the trade
off is more towards the speed we we can
get uh is in blue we can get better
speed but when the tradeoff is more
towards compression ratio speed is
reduced although if you throw enough
number of threads I mean this reduction
in a speed is not that that important so
it depends on on your machine if um and
you want to choose one tradeoff or or
another and of course the the
predictions are much better when the
Codex uh that has been
to that has had to be chosen are defer
defers more in in features so for
example in this case in red this blal Z
and in in blue and green is LZ 4 and
both have very very similar features so
the predictions are quite random so to
say however if we choose between Z
standard and blocks LZ which Expos very
different features the predictions are
very very accurate which is the most
important case we want to distinguish
between
this these uh
scenarios here is some testimonials uh
about people using using vune they are
they are very pleased in general to use
that because it provides like a like a
nice feedback for for choose in the
different uh the different
compression uh
parameters so uh in conclusion uh BL two
is providing a Noel way to handle huge
and dimensional arrays representing
large volumes tested up to 8 trillion
cells and can much and more can be done
probably it can be extended via Dynamic
plugins and BT allows for automatic
solation of the best compression paret
all in all BL two represents a highly
efficient and flexible tool for
compressing your data your
way so I always like to to thanks donors
and contracts because without them we it
could be it couldn't be possible to uh
to produce
blos uh anymore and uh and on a more on
a personal note I would like to to thank
new Focus I I been the of the project
sustainability award in
2023 so that will encourage me to to put
uh more enthusiasm in the
project so thank you on behalf of all
the blos um uh team and in case you have
some questions I would be glad to to
take them thank you